Damien Chazel vit une drôle d'année on
vient d'apprendre qu'il sera le
président du prochain Festival de Venise
début septembre un festival que vous
pourrez suivre en intégralité sur Canal+
et avec son dernier film Babylone il a
tout connu
cette fascinante plongée dans le
Hollywood de la fin des années 20 en
pleine transition du muet au parlant
cette déclaration d'amour au cinéma
portée par des acteurs flamboyants
avaient tout pour cartonner au
box-office et remporter des tonnes
d'Oscar et pourtant le film s'est
écroulé en Amérique il n'a pas rencontré
son public et n'a même pas été nommée en
meilleure film aux Oscars
mais heureusement la France a sauvé
Babylone chez nous le film a cartonné il
est devenu le chouchou des critiques et
du public
[Musique]
de quoi mettre du baume au coeur de son
réalisateur puisque Damien Chazel est à
moitié français une culture
franco-américaine qui ne cesse de
revendiquer dans ses films
à l'occasion de la sortie en blu-ray de
Babylone nous avons pu faire une
interview rare où le réalisateur peut
revenir sur son film sur sa carrière sur
ses racines longuement et avec du recul
un moment vraiment unique que nous avons
partagé avec Damien et maintenant avec
vous on a commencé l'entretien justement
en parlant racine
est-ce que vous racines françaises
jouent dans votre cinéphilie dans votre
façon de travailler dans votre façon de
réaliser des films oui je pense c'est
c'est
je me souviens quand j'habitais à Paris
j'avais environ 13 ans 14 ans quelque
chose comme ça et c'était
avant avant cette époque là j'adorais
déjà le cinéma je voulais faire du
cinéma mais j'étais pas vraiment un
cinéphile un vrai cinéphile c'est
vraiment à Paris que j'ai découvert la
vraie cinéphilie utilisant Paris scope
chaque semaine et voyons où je pouvais
trouver les vieux films des films que je
ne pouvais pas trouver sur le grand
écran chez moi aux États-Unis parce que
j'étais en Nutella dans une petite ville
aux États-Unis il y avait pas oui on
pouvait voir les grands spectacles de
Hollywood mais pas beaucoup d'autres
alors qu'à Paris je pense toujours que
Paris est vraiment le la ville du
cinéphili et donc d'avoir l'occasion de
voir des films russes des films de
Tchécoslovaquie des films japonais et
des vieux films des dans un email du
documentaire des classiques des
films de de n'importe où sur le grand
écran sur des écrans panoramiques
c'était vraiment comme ça que j'ai
découvert le cinéma entier je dirais
donc donc je pense oui c'est vrai que
c'était assez fondateur pour moi
comme signifie les comme Sénégal
le cinéma France c'est à jouer un rôle
important pour moi mais aussi je sais
pas cette espèce de dialogue entre
l'Amérique et la France Hollywood et le
cinéma français c'est là où on trouve
pour moi on trouve des cinéastes comme
2000 ou comme toute la Nouvelle Vague un
peu une réponse française au film de
genre américain tout ça toute cette
histoire de de liaison de dialogues de
rapport entre le cinéma américain le
cinéma français m'a toujours fasciné
cette histoire et cette tradition
cinématographique oui s'enfonce dans ce
que je fais pour moi
d'être un peu partagé entre les deux
pays les deux cultures entre la France
et l'Amérique ça a toujours fait partie
de mon
ce que je sentais mon identité tout ça
donc je suis pas si c'est un avantage
mais c'est quelque chose de spécifique
de particulier et donc je pense que
c'est bien quand qu'on peut utiliser
ce qui est particulier
le cinéma c'est toujours un loot entre
ce qu'il y a dans la tête et ce qui a
dans le monde réel bah c'est basé qui
parlait de ça parfois un film comme
d'hab ou il faut de la collaboration il
faut une équipe il faut beaucoup de gens
de juste pour pour le faire c'est à dire
qu'il y a je dirais pas des compromis
mais mais oui des luttes des batailles
des changements
c'est assez facile d'écrire bon un
éléphant dans une fête et puis oui les
cercles d'enfer une bataille sur le sur
le champ et tout ça puis après on fait
la transition de l'écrivain au
réalisateur on arrive sur le Platon
chaque jour je regardais le scénario
j'étais
moi donc
ça va être bon c'est vrai que c'était
pas facile mais c'était un challenge
inspirant c'était un peu l'enjeu du film
d'écrire quelque chose avec une espèce
de folie là dedans il fallait un film
fou pour vraiment capter
l'esprit de folie qui existait à
l'époque
vous allez tirer tout ce qui s'est passé
autour du film ça s'est pas très bien
marché ici ça fait partie de l'aventure
de n'importe quel film quoi donc on sait
jamais exactement ce qui va se passer
comme j'ai dit c'était assez facilement
au niveau même sociologie justement
comment les les différents pays ont
réagi différemment
au film alors que c'est le même film
comment vous expliquer que public
français a été aussi sensible à votre
film en fait c'est un peu un mystère je
suis pas je suis pas exactement sûr bon
bien sûr pour moi comme quelqu'un avec
de la famille en France ça me donnait
beaucoup de joie de de trouver que le
film marche bien là-bas et que que les
Français répondaient au film c'est c'est
vrai que c'était un peu génial c'était
un rêve quoi de tourner un film en
France avec des acteurs français tout en
français ah oui c'est ça moderne
qu'est-ce que vous attendez
le sujet je sais pas le scénario on va
voir
un jour
la prochaine fois que nous verrons
Damien Chazel ce sera donc sur le tapis
rouge de la Mostra de Venise ce sera
donc sur Canal+
[Musique]